les chanteurs eux était à la pêche aux
trophées hier soir à l'occasion des 17e
victoire de la musique est au zénith un
palmarès sans grande surprise les
valeurs sûres de la chanson française
ont été récompensés zazie de palmas
voulzy manu chao et noir désir noir
désir le groupe de rock bordelais qui en
a profité pour pousser un coup de gueule
anne charline lambard hills avait voulu
la télévision depuis plus de dix ans les
noir désir ont récupéré le temps perdu
hier soir ils seront les plus primés
avec deux victoires celle du clip et du
meilleur album rock et camp bordelais
assure le show même et là où on ne
l'attend pas merci camarade pdg tu
permets que je t'appelle camarades je
suis obligé de te tutoyer par la même
occasion c'est d'usagé
et puis c'est mieux que au grand jean
marie messier commandeur des
communicants et puis d autres aussi par
la grâce de la sainte trinité
ramifications absorption profit le
message égratigne sans ménagement le
patron de vivendi universal la maison de
disques de noir désir
allez salut à toi camarade pdg de la
nouvelle internationale d'universal nous
ne sommes pas dupes de ton manège et si
nous sommes tous embarqués sur la même
planète
on est décidément pas du même monde à
l'insolence des noirs désirs contraste
un palmarès consensuel qui récompense
les succès commerciaux sous le vent de
garou est sacrée chanson de l'année
gerald de palmas artiste masculin de
l'année il a dit
artiste féminine
enfin la découverte de l'année c'est lui
benjamin biolay pas tout à fait une
découverte l'année dernière son talent a
déjà été récompensé il avait composé
pour l'album d'henri salvador des
victoires décidément sans en turquie
si on voit